>>> AS STORIES OF SURVIVAL AND
RESCUE EMERGE OM THE HOLIDAY
WEEKEND'S DEADLY STORM, SO ARE
STORIES OF SELFLESSNESS AND
COMMUNITY.
ONE MAN IN BUFFALO DEDICATED HIS
TIME AND HIS RESOURCES TO HELP
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
STUCK IN THEIR HOMES.
SOME IN THE COLD WITH NO FOOD OR
POWER, AND HE IS HERE WITH US
NOW, MARK JOHNSON.
WELL, MARK, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US.
WHAT WAS IT THAT MADE YOU DECIDE
TO START HELPING PEOPLE AFTER
THE STORM?
>> THERE WAS A NUMBER OF THINGS,
BUT I'D SAY THE NUMBER ONE THING
WAS THAT I LOST A FRIEND WHO WAS
VERY CLOSE TO ME.
AND WE CALLED HIM YODA.
BUT I LOST HIM, AND I KNEW HOW
SCARED HE WAS.
I JUST COULD IMAGINE HOW SCARED
HE WAS.
HE WAS ACTUALLY MURDERED.
SO, THERE WAS A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT MADE ME JUST THINK, I WOULD
NEVER WANT ANYBODY THAT SCARED
OR THAT ALONE BY THEMSELVES.
SO, IF I COULD HELP ANYBODY,
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO DO.
AND THE TYPE OF SPIRIT THAT HE
HAD, HE'D WANT TO HELP
EVERYBODY.
SO, THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I WANTED
TO DO.
I WANTED TO CHANNEL MY EMOTIONS
AND PUT IT IN THAT WAY BECAUSE
BUFFALO, IT'S A CITY OF LOVE.
>> IT'S JUST INCREDIBLE WHAT
YOU'VE BEEN DOING AND ALL THE
GENEROSITY YOU'VE SHOWN.
TELL US A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
WHAT SUPPLIES YOU'VE BEEN
HANDING OUT, HOW YOU'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GET THESE DONATIONS, AS
WELL.
>> SO, AS FAR AS SUPPLIES, IT
HONESTLY RANGES FROM PEANUT
BUTTER TO INHALERS TO DRIVING
PEOPLE TO DIALYSIS, TO DIGGING
OUT THEIR YARDS SO THAT THEY CAN
GET TO ALL THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
WHO HAVE BEEN TRAPPED OR THEY
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM.
WE HAVE DIAPERS.
WE HAVE -- I'VE LEARNED SO MUCH
ABOUT DIAPERS.
AND ANOTHER THING THAT WE DID
WAS YESTERDAY, I DECIDED, YOU
KNOW WHAT?
EVERYBODY THAT WANTED TO
CONTRIBUTE -- EVERYBODY IS LIKE,
START A GOFUNDME OR DO THIS.
WE WANT TO HELP YOU.
THANK YOU FOR -- IT'S NOT ABOUT
MONETARY GAIN.
IT'S NOT ABOUT TRYING TO GET A
DOLLAR OFF SOMEBODY'S
DESPERATION.
THAT'S NOT WHAT IT'S ABOUT.
SO, I WANTED TO TRY AND PUSH
THAT.
SO, EVERYBODY THAT WANTED TO
CONTRIBUTE, I JUST SAID, CALL
INTO TO KENSINGTON PIZZA, SAY
YOU WANT TO DONATE TO THE DREAM,
AND YOU'LL BUY A SLICE OF PIZZA
OR WHATEVER YOU CAN AFFORD FOR
SOMEBODY ELSE.
WE DONATED I THINK MAYBE OVER
200 PIZZAS.
>> I SEE A LOT OF BABY SUPPLIES
THERE.
AND YOU ACTUALLY HELPED A MOTHER
AND HER BABY, RIGHT?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
IT HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON ME
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE WHEN I GOT
THERE AND I SEEN THAT A MOTHER
WAS HANDLING HER BABY 72-PLUS
HOURS, SWITCHING ON AND OFF WITH
HER HUSBAND, TO KEEP HER BABY
ALIVE IN THE DEPLORABLE
CONDITIONS.
IT WAS FREEZING COLD.
YOU COULD SEE THEIR BREATH.
YOU COULD SEE HOW THEY DIDN'T
HAVE ANYTHING AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THE SNOW WAS PROBABLY WAIST DEEP
FOR A QUARTER OF A MILE WALK
JUST TO GET TO A ROAD.
SO, THERE WAS NO -- WHY WOULD
YOU TAKE THAT CHANCE?
IT WAS BETTER FOR HER.
I APPLAUD HER 100%.
THE STRENGTH AND THE WILL OF A
MOTHER, I COULD NEVER, EVER
DOUBT, EVER AGAIN.
SHE WAS HAVING AN ASTHMA ATTACK
WHILE SHE WAS WALKING HER BABY
THROUGH WAIST DEEP SNOW WITH NO
SHOES ON BECAUSE THEY FELL IN
THE SNOW, SO SHE JUST KEPT
GOING.
I'M LIKE, GIVE ME THE BABY, I'LL
HANDLE THE BABY WHILE WE GET
THERE.
I PROBABLY WALKED THE BABY MAYBE
SEVEN MINUTES THROUGH THE SNOW.
AS SOON AS HE GATHERED HER
BREATH, HE WENT RIGHT BACK TO
HER BABY.
AND I'M STILL GATHERING MY
BREATH.
I'M LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF SHE CAN DO THIS AND I'M IN A
SITUATION OR I'M FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO HELP OTHER PEOPLE,
THEN I SHOULD BE DOING THAT.
>> HOW DO YOU KNOW WHERE TO GO,
WHAT TO DO, EVERY MOMENT OF THE
DAY, WHERE TO FIND THESE
FAMILIES IN NEED?
>> SO, THERE'S ACTUALLY A GROUP
THAT I'D LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
CALLED THE BUFFALO BLIZZARD
GROUP '22.
AND IT'S SAVED A LOT OF LIVES.
AND THE ONLY REASON WHY I KNEW
IS BECAUSE SOMEBODY SAID, HEY,
POST THIS INSIDE THIS GROUP.
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO FIND MORE
PEOPLE TO HELP.
AND I'M LIKE, ALL RIGHT, SEND ME
THE LINK.
THEY ADDED ME, THEY INVITED ME
TO IT.
AND IT HAD 15,000 PEOPLE.
AND IN THERE IS PEOPLE SAYING,
HEY, MY NEIGHBOR CAN'T GET OUT.
I CAN'T GET OUT.
CAN SOMEBODY PLEASE DIG ME OUT?
I'M LOSING ELECTRICITY?
PEOPLE ARE LIKE, I'M FREEZING
COLD.
MY BATTERY IS GOING TO DIE.
I FEEL LIKE MY KIDS ARE GOING TO
DIE.
CAN SOMEBODY HELP ME?
THESE ARE THE THINGS I'M
READING.
IT WAS GOD'S WILL.
GETTING THROUGH THE SNOW, I
DIDN'T GET HURT, I DIDN'T GET
INTO ANY ACCIDENTS, I DIDN'T GET
STUCK.
THIS GROUP WAS PUSHING ME AND
PUSHING ME TO SAY, HEY, IF I
HAVE A WARM HOUSE, IF I HAVE
SOMETHING I CAN DONATE, WHY AM I
NOT DONATING?
THIS IS LIFE OR DEATH.
NOBODY'S GOING TO HELP US RIGHT
NOW.
IT'S REALLY JUST US.
IT'S THE COMMUNITY.
>> WOW.
AND SUCH A REMARKABLE WAY, THE
WAY THAT YOU HAVE JUST IMPACTED
SO MANY OF THESE FAMILIES IN
NEED,